in russland die ukraine angreift wird
das wohl mit flächenbombardements und
raketenangriffen beginnen dabei würden
zivilisten sterben egal welche
nationalität sie habe
eine bodenoffensive würde bedeuten dass
eine gewaltige menge an truppen
einrücken würde ohne weitere vorwarnung
wenig wenn man das hört dramatische
worte aus den usa sie haben familie
freunde in kiew natürlich als
botschafter wie nah sind wir vor dem
krieg
also wir haben schon ein gefühl dass ein
krieg er immer unausweichlicher werte es
herrsche ein gefühl der angst
selbstverständlich weil wir diese gefahr
vor augen seit wochen seit monaten sehen
auf der anderen seite was wir auch sehen
und spüren ist die entschlossenheit der
menschen
ihre heimat zu verteidigen und zwar mit
allen mitteln die uns zur verfügung
stehen und da ist auch nach wie vor
unsere bitte an die deutsche politik
umzudenken und es gibt noch die letzte
chance diesen krieg zu verhindern
diplomatische aber
wir müssen gleichzeitig auch die
richtigen schritte unternehmen wenn ich
sage wir das heißt die deutschen freunde
die partner die wir haben wir zählen auf
sie wir zählen auf diese einsicht dass
man natürlich diplomatisch weiterhin
agieren muss aber das reicht leider
nicht aus herr trittin wiener stehen wir
vor einem krieg mitten in europa muss
man sagen zwei flugstunden hier von
berlin entfernt das ist eine sehr offene
frage die fakten die
auf dem grund erkennbar sind das den
aufmärschen angeht was die nachgezogene
versorgungs kräfte der russen angeht das
sind jetzt nicht mehr nur kampfgruppen
und ähnliche dinge die sagen sie seien
in der lage diese invasion tatsächlich
auszuführen die offene frage ist ob sie
sich dazu entschieden haben dann gibt es
zwischen den diensten wenn ich das sehe
sehr unterschiedliche interpretationen
ich glaube dass in dieser situation es
richtig gewesen ist dass beiden mit
putin gesprochen hat dass es richtig ist
das makro mit putin spricht und das ist
wichtig ist dass der deutsche
bundeskanzler am montag nach kia fährt
und am dienstag dann mit putin spricht
denn es muss ihm klar gemacht werden
dass das worauf putin heute setzen
könnte nämlich eine militärische
eskalation
alles riskiert was er in beziehung mit
europa hat wirtschaftlich und politisch
hamster auf das hören wir häufig man
muss härter mit putin sprechen jetzt
sagen die amerikaner am mittwoch beginnt
möglicherweise der krieg das können sie
nicht belegen wir wissen nicht was putin
entscheiden wird wir wissen nicht ob es
ein befehl gegeben hat was jack sullivan
da verkündet hat ist ein denkbares
szenario
es ist kein belegte szenario und
deswegen müssen wir und das ist der
appell auch des bundespräsidenten heute
in seiner rede müssen wir alles dafür
tun dafür zu sorgen dass es nicht dazu
kommt denn wir dürfen nicht vergessen
botschafter namik hat das gerade gesagt
in der ukraine gibt es eine große
entschlossenheit das land zu verteidigen
das eigene land die heimat zu
verteidigen mit allen zur verfügung
stehenden mitteln das heißt das wird
nicht eine leichte operation für den
fall dass ich die russen dazu
entschließen sollten der trainer hat
gerade gesagt sollten die russen
wirklich da einmarschieren würde alles
zusammenbrechen was es an beziehungen
gibt zwischen russland und dem westen so
dass sie im grunde nur noch die chance
haben sich in china anzulegen das heißt
sie hätten eine widerständige ukraine
die versuchen wollen zu kontrollieren
sie hätten wir die beziehungen zum
westen völlig kaputt und während total
abhängig von china das ist nicht im
russischen nationalen interesse aus dem
ausland bislang nicht aufgehalten zu
haben er hat eben immer weitere truppen
an der grenze zusammen zu ziehen und
jetzt gibt es eben diese aussagen aus
den usa warum macht man das denn dort
dann so konkret wenn via lambsdorff und
andere sagen man ist so genau auch
wieder nicht weil es eine konkrete
gefahr ist und zunächst mal mit
alexander lambsdorff recht geben wenn
die gegenwärtige diskussion etwas zeigt
dass dann der dass der plan von putin
durch seine
überfall auf die krim und den einfluss
in der ost ukraine vor acht jahren das
auf diese weise ein stück weit die
ukraine
rausholt aus dieser europafreundlichkeit
dass das nicht eingetreten ist sondern
dass im gegenteil dieser russische druck
über die vielen jahre das hat den
menschen geholfen sie haben sich in
europa ausgedrückt und am ende werden ja
also sie werden nicht alleingelassen zu
werden wirtschaftlich und politisch
massiv unterstützt von europa nicht
zuletzt auch von deutschland die
wirtschaftliche entwicklung der ukraine
ist eine kategorie ahl bessere seit wir
das als sozia zions abkommen mit der in
ihren haben und diese ganzen maßnahmen
da wird extrem viel getan ich glaube das
weiß die ukrainische bevölkerung auch
aber ich glaube der meinte mond in
diesem land ist eben auch ganz klar dass
man sich von russland nicht pressen
lassen will und das einzige mittel was
putin möglicherweise sieht um seine
politik doch noch zum erfolg zu führen
ist die militärische karte wenn er
vernünftig ist rené rational handelt
wird er diese sache bleiben lassen aber
sind wir sicher dass er tatsächlich in
einer lage ist in der rational handelt
kann es nicht sein dass etwas
irrationales passiert was hinterher
nicht rückholbar ist das ist die große
sorge die ich habe wenig was kann olaf
scholz der deutsche bundeskanzler jetzt
tun er reist morgen nach kiew dann
fliegt er zurück auch um diplomatische
schwierigkeiten zu vermeiden um dann
wieder nach russland zu reisen in
früheren zeiten wäre man natürlich von
kiew direkt weiter nach moskau geflogen
was kann man jetzt tun
wir glauben dass das womöglich auch die
letzte chance sein wird für die
weltgemeinschaft und für herrn schultz
der ja nicht nur als bundeskanzler
sondern vor allem auch als vorsitzender
der g7 staaten nach gehe von der nach
moskau fliegt und das einzige was herr
scholz jetzt in seinem gepäck mitnehmen
sollte wäre ein klares ultimatum
sofort aufzuhören mit fristen was
geschieht und zwar tagtäglich ja wenn
die gruppe nicht abgezogen werden am
mittwoch dann werden folgende sanktionen
sofort eingeführt dass man präventiv
agiert und nicht mehr abwarten so die
zeit wurde vergeudet die wertvolle zeit
zwei monate jetzt ist die zeit gekommen
um endlich zu handeln trittin sanktionen
sofort um putin unter druck zu setzen
ich glaube dass der weg den wir und zwar
die deutsche bundesregierung sei zum
amtes mit mittlerweile zwei der
bundesaußenminister in kiew einem besuch
in moskau mit dem jetzt vorgesehenen
diplomatie durch den bundeskanzler mit
dem in der letzten woche stattgefunden
habenden verhandlungen im normandie
format zwischen siemann geführt haben
genauso wie die besucher so ist das so
ist das immer dass bei diplomatie sie
nicht morgens ein ergebnis haben wenn
sie sich abends treffe aber man wünscht
sich ja dann schon dass zumindest die
sache ist nicht weiter eskaliert wie sie
heute nur darauf hinweisen hatte es
keine passivität gegeben und es gibt in
der nächsten woche donnerstag erneut ein
treffen in diesem format das heißt
deutschland kümmert sich nicht nur darum
das assoziationsabkommen mit der ukraine
mit leben zu füllen dort massiv zu
investieren
ich habe erst in der letzten woche
hennig war dabei die stellvertretende
ministerpräsidentin der ukraine
getroffen wo wir über fragen der
wirtschaftlichen zusammenarbeit
gearbeitet haben sondern eben auch mit
klaren botschaften richtung russland ist
es nicht so dass man das nur auf
diplomatie und worte beschränkt die
antwort die europa hierzu gegeben hat
war sehr eindeutig und sie war auch
eindeutig im konzert der nato das heißt
zwischen europa und den usa abgestimmt
wir werden eine weitere man muss das
wort weiter immer unterstreichen
russland verletzt täglich die
territoriale integrität der ukraine in
donezk
im don was in dieser situation wie sind
in einer solchen situation wir werden
das weiter nicht akzeptieren und auf
dieser basis sprechen wir und wenn es
auf dieser basis keine einigung gibt
wenn es eskalieren und gibt es eine
antwort darauf wie viel angst haben sie
persönlich vor einem krieg sie waren
teil einer bundesregierung die damals
den kosovo krieg miterlebt hat wo
schwere entscheidungen für die grünen
getroffen werden mussten was macht das
mit ihnen persönlich ich glaube dass wir
aus dieser situation eines gelernt haben
dass man wirklich alles tun muss um eine
solche militärische eskalation zu
vermeiden das ist glaube ich auch der
erfahrungshintergrund den olaf scholz in
diese gespräche mit einbringt
dennoch ich kann niemandem ernsthaft
sagen
ich bin ich glaube ich hier im breiten
konsens dass das nicht stattfinden würde
ich würde auch sagen mit herrn hart es
gibt eine überragende wahrscheinlichkeit
dass es nicht im interesse russlands ist
militärisch zu eskalieren aber wenn ich
mir anschaue mit welcher intensität
beispielsweise putin locker schenker in
belarus gestützt hat das modell des
machtverlustes vor augen es war sichtbar
das war sein eigenes menetekel was an
dieser stelle gewesen war da weiß ich
nicht was die rationalität ist der landy
freund nämlich die rationalität der
erhaltung der herrschaft auch um einen
sehr hohen preis möglicherweise auch um
den preis eines blutigen krieges in der
ukraine und es findet den billa russia
dieses referendum statt dieses gefakte
von lukaschenko und eine maßnahme das
haben wir letzte woche und auch noch mal
mit dem oscar diskutiert in vilnius eine
maßnahme ist den artikel aus der
verfassung der von belarus zu streichen
dass belarus ein atomwaffenfreies land
ist das heißt im klartext wenn diese
verfassung so angenommen wird was ja
angesichts der fälschung liter
stattfindet klar ist kann lukaschenko
jederzeit putin einladen atomwaffen an
der polnischen grenze zu stationieren
also ich bin schon beunruhigt dass da
möglicherweise auch noch einen bahnhof
opladen dahin tragen sie alle nehmen sie
jetzt mal alle zusammen außerdem
ukrainischen botschafter in den
vergangenen zehn 15 jahren auch die
kanzlerin zu naiv was wladimir putin
angeht man hat immer gehofft ja mensch
wenn man mit ihm spricht wenn man
versucht das verhältnis zu verbessern
dann wird schon jetzt nichts großes
weiteres passieren okay die krim das ist
jetzt so die ost ukraine
aber jetzt stehen wir möglicherweise vor
einer riesigen umfassenden invasion die
dazu führen kann dass hunderttausende
menschen sterben millionen flüchtlinge
es geben könnte mit in europa wir haben
potato tal überschätzt als führer
russlands was die entwicklung des
eigenen landes angeht wir haben gedacht
wenn putin mit unserer unterstützung mit
dem riesigen erlösen aus den gas- und
ölverkäufen wenn er damit russland zu
einer modernen nationen des 21
jahrhunderts macht ein stück weit näher
die eu bringt den handels und
wirtschaftsfragen dann werden wir auf
diese weise auch den frieden sichern wir
haben aber leider festgestellt dass
putin ein ziemlich erfolglos in der
innenpolitik in der wirtschaft mit
ziemlicher vor großer präsident ist in
russland die infrastruktur die
diversifizierung der industrie was ist
ihnen wichtig das war die naivität dass
wir das wir putin wahrscheinlich in
seiner kraft russland nach vorne zu
bringen total überschätzt haben so dass
wir jetzt erleben dass er nur die
militärische karte noch spielen kann